*Epic music intro*
*God Pewdiepie*
HA HA scared ya!
You should've seen the look  of your fac--
Oh, my god, Ainsley
Try not to get scaaaared challenge
No, I'm not running out of ideas *nervous laugh*
So, I scared you pretty good
I know
Now it's your turn to scare ME!
And see if you can scare me
Luckily, I'm PewDiePie
I never get scared
*A few old memories*
So this should be a pretty easy challenge
Don't you think?
*Trying to escape*
I tweeted out for you guys to scare me
Now let's see how it went
Alright, first link
*FNAF Song*
Oh, my god!
Oh, my God
It's Leafy
No! God.
Is this gonna jumpscare me. I-I... *nervous laugh*
Hey! Leafy here
Hello?
*Leafy appears*
*scared laugh?*
I knew it was coming
I knew it was gonna happen
It still sca--
I MEAN!
It didn't scare me!
Oh, look who got scared! ha ha
Wait, what the fuck is this?
Ainsley *huffs*
Are you--
Are you a kinder egg?
*rhinoceros snorting cocaine sound*
Wow
Wow, guys *slow claps*
I-I really gotta say, uh, woah
Oh, ugh--
Ca--
Tone it down a bit
Cause I-I-I'm getting a little bit too scared right now
Woah!
Jesus Christ!
Is that Markiplier?
Oh, my God!
AH!
God.
DAMMIT!
AHH!
Fuck's sake!
My beautiful Mark!
*grunts* (tf are you doing pewds)
Alright, what do we got here?
*laughs*
Great!
*thumbs up*
A+ so far
What is this?
*laughs*
*laughing* Nooo
No...
That poor kitty!
No! He's getting triggered!
What the f--
Okay
Ooh! That's creepy
That was a good--
Good five-second clip
I think you didn't need the scream part
That was pretty cool
That's pretty--
What the... *exasperated sigh*
You guys are just showing off your fucking pet
Okay, this look pretty scary
God damn it!
God fucking damn it.
You guys suck!
You guys fucking suck, okay?
Oh, no! I've seen this...
No...
Why did I watch this fucking anime as a kid?
It's-s...
The expressions in it are so horrifying, I never forget it
They all scream so much, too. I don´t--
You know, I'd rather watch Boku No Pico than this fucking shit
I swear to God
AGH!
OH!
Ffffffffuck! *hiss*
Ah, the cringe! I can't!
Why did I watch this?!
Oh, Shion. I remember Shion
She used to be nice
And then in another epis--
Uh...
It doesn't--
UGH!!
It didn't go off!
AHH!
Ngahh!
Nah...
Damn it...!
Oh, uh--
Sexual undertones,
A+, Japan
What the fuck.
Whew
Whew...
It gets me every time
Fucking Higurashi, man...
Why did I fucking what that fucking shit...
What's wrong with me?
*laughs*
Scare PewDiePie season 3 coming up, right there
What the fuck? *laughs*
*laughs*
Well, I'm glad it wasn't scary
Jesus Christ
I didn't know... snakes had buttholes
I mean it--
...
It should've been obvious
But now I know!
Oh, God. What is this?
Fuck!
Oh, it's a cat
Whew
Oh, it really scared me, that one
Geez
"A father puts up cameras in his house when his daughter told him--"
Twenty thousand retweets.
I've never seen this
Uuh!
Ohh!
OOHH!
Oh, shit!
What the fuck was that?!
AAAAHH!!
Oh!
Shit!
Fucking papers, man!
I-I'm starting to regret this video...
Oh, God.
Not the fucking snakes!
I didn't realize I had a thing for snakes until I saw a snake...
Oh, my God...
Fuck you...
Oh, I've seen this one...
This is, uhhh...
Made by some Swedish, uhh...
Uhh... people
And they made a full movie c--
Out of it called Lights Out
It's not bad...
But I prefer the short film
It's fucking creepy as shit, man
*grunts*
Just stop!
Just stop doing that.
Listen, if I saw a disgusting naked ass
I would be scared like that as well.
You just got beaned
*EARRAPE INTENSIFIES
I gotta click away!
I nearly died!
What is this...?
Great...
*Spanish*
Oh...
Ohhhh no
No
Stop.
Please stop.
Oh, my God
*Whoosh* Top of the morning to ya laddies! my name is Jacksepticeye
*Whoosh* TOp Of the MoRNiNG tO Ya LaDdIes! my NamE iS JACksEpticEyE
*Bunch of pot8toes yelling*
*Whoosh* TOp Of the MoRRRNiNG tO Ya LaDdIes! my NamE iS JACksEpticEyE!!!!
*Chaos*
NO!
I can't do this!
Ainsley...
If I don't make it back...
Tell the King
Tell the King about my bravery
*Heroic music*
Warning :v